in many cases in a growth in the case
situation you will be given K now
remember I told you that that is
sometimes called the growth rate
hopefully you can be saying this enough
that it sort of soaks in I think a much
better name for it is the growth
constant because that tells you I did
big you'll see what it is and that's
just a number it doesn't change your
given scenario ok after you mean live at
the great concert but just as frequently
you'll be given a question like this and
the growth constant is something you
have to work out in order to solve the
question so let's have a look at this
time a bacterial population doubles in
this amount of time I love it's like the
more mass you know the less information
you need to be able to work out so
before we answer it
I just want to get it your intuition if
you think it takes 24 hours to double
how long will it take to quadruple this
is not intuition this is just you can
answer that right if it takes a day to
be doubled then to double again which is
quadrupling it'll just take two lots of
this 48 hours yeah so what would your
intuition down telling you
Triple E to take just a rough guess what
do you think
36 maybe like if what day doubles and
two days quadruples then triples is
somewhere between those so 36 hours not
a bad guess let's just think about that
because like I said in mathematics you
should always make a guess because then
if you turn that right it's like cool if
you're wrong we can learn something in
sea cow and powerful let's have a go at
this I'm going to set up an equation for
beans right I'm gonna say well if the
bacterial population is growing and
normally the question would say this but
I'm just going to let you a stupid for
now if the bacterial population is
growing at a rate in proportion to its
science then it will follow this kind of
equation right where B naught is my
initial condition my initial population
K is my growth constant
and T is my time up government hours
okay now interesting leash I don't know
anything about the growth once at the
top nothing and I don't even know where
the population begins that's one of
those wonderful things about exponential
growth decay this first sentence I'm
going to use it and make a particular
version of this this statement like at a
particular time this is at any time but
at a particular time I can make a
statement so I could say when the tie
beers
well after 24 hours even though I don't
know what the bacterial population is I
can state it in terms of the information
I know it's double what I started with
right so it's going to be 2 times B dot
whatever B naught is okay so it could be
Alison like we looked at that question
before or actually a thousand is a tiny
man bacterias for me the millions right
so given this I can substitute that in
here and that will give you interesting
all right so I could say therefore V
naught e to the know my time here is 24
so I'm gonna write instead of KT I'm
gonna write it's ready for okay
is that a chance that's the right hand
side the left hand side B the actual
population is to lots of the initial
population
yeah now just like we saw before with
the thousand that V naught it just
cancels out right this will happen over
and over again when you have some time
take it like this now I'm trying to find
K right look I've got an equation here
I've gotten rid of all of the other
unknowns so I just need to rearrange
this and make K the subject what should
I do both sides take logs for both sides
that leaves you 24 K on the left hand
side and the natural log of 2 on the
right hand side you can see I'm pretty
much there on time I'm just going to
divide through and now I have a value
for K sir
it wasn't given to us in the question
but if you know something about how it's
how fast it's growing at a particular
time that's all you need to find out K
because
that's what chaos okay lovely how about
you use that to actually answer the
question good sir I now know what this
number is
I used an initial condition sorry I've
got an additional cushion an eventual
condition to find K I solve for K now I
want to solve for time like how long
that's a time question right
using this view K okay so I'm going to
say bacteria triples when and then I'm
going to make the statement be that this
is the population at a particular time
is as I've said triple the initial
condition right so now I'm solving I've
got B naught e to the zero and we'll
just point out I'm gonna write we're
gonna go ahead and write this thing okay
but because if it finicky to write and
you're also ready you're up in that your
desk you will sometimes see textbooks
are like solutions they will keep on
writing K even though they know what K
is until the last moment whether okay
now I need to need the numbers for this
and so I'm going to stop writing K even
though it's a bit quicker for me okay
but I'm going to go ahead and write it
anyway one on 24 long - time time of
course is still T because I don't know
what it is yet that's what I meant to
solve for and that's equal to three lots
of benign just like we saw before kids
or kids or I'm solving for time
just like before when I was it obvious
in a tentacle situation you've got e to
the whatever and that whatever has the
thing you're trying to solve for
so I'll take lots of both sides that
leaves me with this and it's pretty
trivial to get to a solution for ticket
isn't it I'm going to divide through by
1 on 24 long 2 which gives me 24 log 3
on log 2 which is going to give you a
can i has a displaces okay so b then i
got the original time to the new stay
I'm gonna give my wallet cell to the
news owl it takes approximately 38 hours
now remember our guess was what again 36
now that was a good guess that was
pretty good right we were just a little
bit on the earliest side right in fact
he took a little bit longer to get to
triple what is that
I can't burn I think I get where ask
away but let me see if I can put some
numbers on this to see if we can get the
same intuition that Rask on his head
okay let's go back to the original
situation of saying we started in 2000
so we know after 24 hours right we're
going to get to 2000 and then another 24
hours we're going to get to 4,000 does
that make sense it's doubling every day
okay now we were after that 3000 point
now you marry me that's somewhere in the
middle somewhere it is exactly in the
middle
however because it's exponential growth
to grow from 2000 to 3000 takes longer
than it does to go from a 3000 to 5000
do you see why do you see why because
once you're at 3000 you'll be gone and
it's exponential growth okay so you are
growing faster because Eisley because
you are bigger right so being that it's
the same amount the same distance that
you have to grow well obviously you're
going to be able to cover that same
distance faster when you're bigger
naturally if you're like okay I've got a
million of us now it'll take you like a
split second to grow another thousand
okay so the larger you are or you can
see it makes about a difference of well
14 hours to do that 2,000 or 3,000 and
then only 10 hours to do the 3,000 to
4,000 does that make sense so you can
see how intuition was pretty good but
exponential growth decay tells you why
as rapper saying you sort of leaning
more this way
the last bit okay it goes faster right
and this is always the situation with
exponential growth in account okay